I love the series I'm really happy to
get to talk to you guys about it
um uh for anyone who's watched the
series they know this is essentially an
eight-hour movie like I can't imagine
the challenges you guys were both up
against to try to make this thing happen
so for both of you I know the obstacles
were crazy but what were like what's one
obstacle for each of you that you were
like I don't know how we're gonna solve
this
is
when you ask that question the truth of
it is uh it was Monumental so we started
very early in prep while Scripps were
still being written uh uh uh visual
effects started very early uh and uh
production I actually all of us started
very early in the process the writer's
room was going and we get pages and we
look at each other and go oh my God I
will do this I mean seriously uh every
single aspect of it how do you create
create a cave world how do you create
the the scene on the uh on the ocean uh
and all of those things so it was truly
a nuanced a breakdown breakdown with a
overlying communication it was the
collaboration between
um production design uh Kate's work and
visual effects and all the Departments
working together uh no silos uh the the
walls were completely opened up so we
worked together to come up with these
possible solutions do you want to add
anything from costumes no
um no absolutely and I think I think it
was because the nature was communication
between departments and um there was a
little element of a pandemic that
actually became a good tool out of that
came good tools to be able to do that
sharing information and that so and with
you know the speed that we were going at
being able to share information across
um each other's departments was so
important you you know there is that
tendency to want to hit and run on your
own just to get it done but you couldn't
you know with the
um the challenges that we were trying
um to work with and you know issues like
scale and creature work and that you you
had to collaborate so it was it was a
great exciting thing to be specific and
not avoid the question I think scale is
a really good one so we know that we
have uh big and small in the same frame
uh we're going to have act multiple
actors playing the same character how do
those costumes work what are the skills
how do we keep it consistent it has to
be scientific you cannot cheat at scale
if you say uh this character is this
height the other character is that
height there's no like fudging it's not
like oh if you're a couple of inches off
it really looks wrong uh if you don't
shoot it uh uh I used to come to the top
with all these charts you'd have lots of
meetings like this and Ron would come in
with the whole previous all the time and
you know forced perspective uh only
works if you're a precise so it was all
those things and The Telltale giveaways
of costume not being scaled properly or
set deck not making a piece of furniture
or um a cup or something in the frame
not be exactly right those were the
things and those were the details that
we hung on and we made sure we're
absolutely correct across the board
individual questions
um Ron I read that this is and I could
be wrong but I read this is the first
show that was all like cloud-based in
terms of of just everything
post-production you name it all
cloud-based uh talk a little bit about
about making this happen and do you
think this is the future of every
production yes the answer is yes to the
last question it is the future and it is
actually the present it's already moving
so rapidly when we started we were a
Amazon show so I asked Amazon both Prime
and AWS could we be fully cloud-based
and they thought for a moment and said
yes so they allowed us to do it and we
started to build tools it was
transparent to everyone no Department
really uh it wasn't a big thing to each
department but underlyingly the whole
thing was built on a cloud-based um
platform and uh it made it possible to
get the work done uh to Kate and uh and
Ramsey we just communicated all the time
in ways that most shows can't because of
the fact that we were uh
cloud-based and anything could be shared
at any time anywhere you were yeah I
can't imagine though uh how scared you
were if everything was in the cloud and
the redundancies that must have been
needed to make sure things were not lost
that is a fascinating question that's
what I thought you should have seen we
went into it with that mindset and we
made multiples of everything we had uh
petabytes of data and we realized we
didn't need any of it at the end we
threw away uh a bunch of it because we
didn't need the redundancy it actually
is safe and it works beautifully it
actually I became a True Believer after
uh not it didn't break not once Kate I
definitely want to know the I don't I
can't imagine the challenges of trying
to create costumes for essentially an
eight-hour movie so talk a little bit
about what amazing but I'm being
completely serious you have so many
characters and each one comes from a
different part of Middle Earth and so
can you sort of talk about not only the
the the the the the Practical problem of
trying to design all these costumes but
then coming up with the looks of each of
these costumes and where do you find
inspiration what art movements are you
pulling from are you pulling from the
Moon you know like there's just
everything is just a massive challenge
so you've got to
um there's the whole lack of Middle
Earth and I had to start there the
source material and I was very familiar
already with Lord of the Rings and and
The Hobbit I wasn't familiar with the
submarillion until I started this job so
in fact all my crew in my department I
became very familiar with all of the
books so understanding the text
um as the background to understand the
the um the different ages because
there's such contrast between the first
second and third ages
um and understanding where our
characters start and their creation and
where they end both with dwarves and
elves and and with individuals
um uh so we start with the text but then
also
um I think in the natural process of
um research and that you you know also
um look into the world of Tolkien
himself and his influences or the Nordic
in Germanic mythologies
um English folklore his interests in
Arthur and and the Green Knight all of
that world and also his own
contemporaries you know there's the
pre-raphaelites and Edward Byrne Jones
and all of those painters so I kind of
we filled our rooms with all of this and
and resoundingly the the Thematic nature
of uh Elemental and and
um each culture being being imbued in a
different set of elements you know the
he describes the elves being born on
shores of Pearl and a hero covered in
the dust of diamonds and his words evoke
a lot of
um we actually used to type out whole
um paragraphs in that from tolkien's
works from any of those books and put
them up on the wall and then gradually
so we'd start big like there's some big
sweeps and then we'd start defining
um each element in its relationship to
Nature and its environment and that
would inform materiality and color
palette so it's sort of starting with
bigger elements and then you get down
and down and more into the detail of
each thing but it it helps you put a
sort of you know Peg on each wall and
gives you a map really we had to have a
big map and then we'd sort of be able to
create rules from that for each of the
characters and for each of the cultures
but the commonality was that it was all
based and embedded in nature
and to be clear uh Kate had a a room and
we would go weekly to that room and
within it would be material words
drawings paintings uh Kate's original
art on the wall we would come and go and
we'd all contribute uh production design
visual effects we'd all work together to
uh to so when Kate was talking about the
words of the diamonds and uh all of that
we we brought into the visual effects as
well so the ice ice climb uh has those
elements uh very specifically that are
also mirrored in subtly but in the
costumes as well and in the uh
production design so all of those things
fit together
um somewhat seamlessly one of the things
about this series is that going in you
knew that the world cared this is a show
that's going to be watched all over the
planet it's the number one show on
Amazon on Prime video so what is it like
actually for both of you because it's
crazy hours you have to wear work what
is it like for both of you being part of
a series like this that literally the
entire planet is watching and cares
about well we we can't as well I mean
you know that very much I mean you know
it can be a a burden to
um when you focus on that but you can't
really you've got to go through the
process and do you do your due diligence
which is being as familiarizing yourself
as much with the material as you can and
understand the world so we do the same
process anyone would have and the same
as was done in Lord of the Rings you
know when you read about their research
and process that you know we're all
looking and pulling out the same things
it's how you interpret it and and I
think um for us the second age you know
where the trees give the light as
opposed taking the light in the third
age we're at a time where magic such as
it is is in its um Prime and it's the
Golden Age of elves and dwarves and then
Lord of the Rings magic is fading and
and or and as are the elves in that
world so it's sort of understanding that
and
um
we were very conscious of trying to
um with some of these characters they
we've never seen them before in that but
trying to always go back to Tolkien as a
source if we had no other visual pathway
and working off those descriptions
really as to use as uh our base thing
and we there was an endless discussion
and endless research about elements and
we tried to bring in
um things from the past you know from
the fall of gondolin and elements found
their ways into costume and that so
anyone who knew the source material
would recognize that maybe you know
they've done some of these elements and
I just wanted to add to that that we've
took it as a great responsibility we did
not toss it off we did not we won't
some people would like it some people
wouldn't like it but what we were going
to do was going to do our very best to
realize uh tolkiens what talking told us
so we always went back to talking it was
the thing we did the show Runners did we
did we took it extremely seriously which
sometimes it becomes a conflict between
creating drama and modern culture and
also staying true to the the material so
that was a line that we walked but uh
fully the answer that I would answer to
question is we took the took it with a
great deal of responsibility and care
and a lot of people within my department
you know met Appleton who was an armor
and Daniel Falconer from WETA you know
we had a lot of people have been
involved as myself in past films but
we're ready to look at the material in a
new world but all of them cared and it
was great because it was a debate all
the time before we made certain
decisions on things you know there was a
debate about you know was this true to
um character in that so no one was
allowed to get away with anything you
could be changed you could still make a
decision to do something but there was
no laziness involved in it
people from all over the world we had a
young artists who uh were inspired and
is what brought them into either visual
effects or into some of the craft that
came to uh New Zealand with the hope of
being on the show and we had uh artists
that had been on the original uh Lord of
the Rings that wanted to come back to
Middle Earth and look at it afresh so it
was fascinating and fun yeah I might be
in the minority but I personally uh know
that a TV show needs to do what a TV
show is going to do and the book will
always be the book there's uh you know
but that that's me but I'm almost out of
time if you for each of you if you could
keep a costume that was made for the
series uh which costume would you keep
and why and what and the Wonder you keep
the one that you're keeping is it a
one-off or were like lots made well I'm
fascinated to see what Ron's going to
come up with there I've got some ideas
for Ron but um I think for me funny
enough it would be some of the chain
mail that we created for collateral in
the northern ways because of you know
something that um Tolkien mentioned a
lot male and just you know the way we
you know the bring in the diamonds and
the light and sort of the world of ARA
and valinora you know for me it just
felt the right language for them you
know their interpretation of of a a
familiar element
um I suppose and that also took a lot of
work many hands were bleeding at the end
of that but the chamber was one of the
first things that we did I don't know
it's hard to have favorites really
sometimes they might be the berries we
created or some little element of a
costume rather than the whole for me
personally
the dwarves costume when he comes in to
the Rock breaking contest uh scale
double no it comes in with a small uh
regalia for the rock breaking and cause
I do did we not dress you up at all oh I
don't know
and or for every day where I would wear
the um
I can't believe he wants everyday look
well every day look would be the hard
foot
I I gotta stop there I'm just gonna say
that um I really want to thank you for
your work on the series and um uh Kate I
believe I'll see you later at a certain
screening yes thank you very much so you
guys have a fantastic day thank you for
your time thank you thank you Stephen